bonjour à vous louis merci d'être avec
nous en direct ce matin sur arte france
+2 88% des voix pour denis sassou
n'guesso qui rempile donc pour un
quatrième mandat dans des conditions
particulières puisque je crois qu'il ya
eu des coupures d'internet durant la
journée de scrutin un faible taux de
participation aussi qu'il faut signaler
76 points 55% des voix peut-on parler
d'élections crédibles
déjà il s'agit de résultats provisoires
la la commission le ministre de tutelle
a proclamé les résultats le nahd a
encore la validation par la cour
constitutionnelle
même si le président tchadien a déjà
félicité son homologue le fait est que
nous sommes dans une élection dont le
principal en gt la participation 67%
c'est très flatteur il ya beaucoup de
pays qui paye très cher pour avoir un
tel taux de participation mais le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui une pré
crise de confiance entre les autorités
qui dirigent le bon boîtier et
population est l'une des choses qu'il
faut aussi dire c'est que des dernières
élections
celui qui était arrivé deuxième en
l'occurrence jean marcel jobin et
marcelo coco continue d'être en prison
et donc comment organiser des élections
du ce type est considérée sont
démocratiques
quand on dépose des recours et qu'on ne
fait pas de manifestations illégales ne
se regroupent en cliquant ici tu es
aussi long
la queue de cinq ans qu'il est en prison
et donc tout cela ne concourent pas à
rendre crédible et l'élection
et on le fait qu'on ait coupé garnier
que les sms ne disparaissaient
gouvernement l'a justifié par le fait
que n'était pas à sa demande mais l'ex
dans le déni mais c'est quand même
curieux ces textes des techniques avec
le jour des élections et donc tous ces
accidents
mis bout à bout ne contribue pas à
vendre l'élection crédit aux yeux des
observateurs toujours pas d'alternance
démocratique
au congo brazzaville comment l'expliquer
je pense que le congo brazzaville et
d'endel la droite lignée de la plupart
des pays d'afrique centrale ou à
certains moments en faisant le cumul des
mandats on se rendait compte que c'est
le pays
c'est la zone du monde où les présidents
ont mis le plus de temps au pouvoir que
ce soit en angola
que ce soit au cameroun que ce soit au
gabon que ce soit en bout de chaîne ou
dans d'autres pays voisins
la guinée équatoriale qui aujourd'hui
pas le record de longévité au pouvoir du
président c'est une zone où l'alternance
politique n'est pas à l'ordre du jour et
ce qui est surprenant c'est que ces pays
là continuent de voir que le fait qu'ils
sont des pays où d'après démocratique
mais le lieu mais en creux c'est
connaître ces réformes des constitutions
qui font peu malgré l'âge avancé des
présidents malgré la nécessité
aujourd'hui le mettre en conformité la
classe politique et la population
qu'elle représente
il n'y a pas de possibilité du
changement par lésions et donc on ne
peut qu'être surpris comme les
poussières des présidents ne comprennent
pas la nécessité qu'il ya de donner du
sang neuf à la démocratie de rester en
conformité la population et des vides et
qui est beaucoup trop de frustration
parce que le liste qu'il était fort on
est dans une zone du golfe de guinée où
la piraterie maritime existe ou des
menaces terroristes également exil
et oui a eu un certain nombre de coups
d'état en obtenir plus de cela mais je
crains fort qu'avec cette incapacité du
produit procédé à des alternances
politiques à des changement de
génération par les yeux que l'on retombe
dans une situation qui sera semblable à
celle des années 80 c'est à dire la
dynamique des coups d'état militaires ou
des renversements des régimes par des
mouvements de population alors justement
le pouvoir qu'elle est en place de
missions de garçons lui-même argumente
toujours en évoquant cette fameuse
guerre civile à la fin des années 90
pour justifier justement un bilan mitigé
il faut le dire c'est un pays qui compte
cinq millions d'habitants un pays
pétrolier et 4 40% de la population vit
dans la pauvreté
que peut-il apporter de plus maintenant
du lycée sont des sceaux pour l'instant
ce qu'il pourrait apporter du soutien
aux congolais c'est probablement de
passer la mer la nouvelle génération du
faso en france par la société adoma la
gestion une confiance des postes des
strapontins et de l'associer pleinement
à la gestion du pays et préparer aux
scènes ne sont pas un leader qui
pourrait le remplacer au cas où la
convergence du pouvoir parce qu'il est
quand même incompréhensible que dans un
pays comme le congo qui a moins de 5
millions d'habitants qui nous dessert
plus grand producteur de pétrole de
l'afrique on en soit évacuée d'un
dirigeant politique qui meurent pendant
son évacuation sanitaire parce qu'une
nouvelle prise en charge par les
autorités de son pays veut dire qu'il ya
eu des défaillances possibilités sur le
plan politique que sur le plan de la
gestion des infrastructures
donc je pense qu'il est important au
moins de doter cette funeste population
une facture qui lui permettront de se
sentir à l'aise dans son pays mais
également de pouvoir aux contribuer à la
section développement du pays
tant que ces outils là ne sont pas
développés et que la répression et si
que le mezzo voie à toutes les tous les
subterfuges reste la règle dit peu
démuni a malheureusement à cren
soulèvement et on a donc beaucoup
évidemment on est originaire qui pisse
parfait kolélas on a deux qui doivent
être contenus et pas uniquement par la
force
guy brice parfait kolélas 5 est décédé
du convive 19 parmi les motifs de
contestations de la part de l'opposition
c'est là il ya l'article 70 de la
constitution qui prévoit à un cas de
report ou d'annulation l'élection en cas
de décès de l'un des candidats
quelles sont les chances de voir les
recours de l'opposition aboutir
malheureusement comme pour les résultats
des élections qui peuvent être contestés
devant la cour les jeux soit déjà fait
les jeux sont malheureusement fait avant
l'élection on savait que le président
denis sassou n'guesso
elle est gagnée le principal enjeu
c'était la participation et le score de
ses adversaires donc là dessus on se
disait qu'il y avait encore quelques
quelques inconnues mais aujourd'hui je
pense qui est très peu connu sur le fait
que les résultats tels qu'ils ont été
proclamés soit maintenue mais aucune
dilution maintenant sur la bataille
juridique qui s'ouvre les opinions sont
très divisés il ya des juristes qui
estiment que le candidat a mené campagne
jusqu'au bout et qu'il est décédé le
lendemain du scrutin dont il n'ya pas il
n'y a pas matière à annuler l'élection
ça c'est la position du camp de denis
sassou n'guesso est dans l'opposition et
a non seulement ces soupçons de fraudes
qui ont été évoquées par plusieurs
rumeurs notamment mathias dzon et puis
également cette question du décès de
l'un des candidats qui fait que beaucoup
essaierons de trouver les arguments pour
détruire la crédibilité de l'élection
mais n'est pas certain qu'ils aient
suffisamment de force à la fois sur le
plan juridique et sur le plan populaire
ou inverser les résultats tels qu'ils
ont été proclamés d'autant plus que même
des observateurs internationaux y
compris ceux de l'union africaine ont
admis qu'ils avaient des preuves qui
avait des choses qui n'ont pas été tout
à fait dans la conformité de ce qu'on
attend d'une élection mais que tout cela
ne contribue pas à changer radicalement
le résultat des élections
donc je pense que la ligne qui est
aujourd'hui suivi et la tendance qui
serait également suivi par la cour
constitutionnelle pour confirmer la
réélection de denis sassou n'guesso et
tout à l'heure lui parler du dans ce
tableau taux de participation c'est ce
qui aurait été content a constaté le
jour du scrutin alors que les autorités
affichent un taux de participation je le
disais tout à l'heure de 67 55% ce qu'un
chiffre aussi apprendre à des avec des
pincettes comme vous le disiez oui ça
prendrait des pins cdc sur google
nous sommes de voir une population
aujourd'hui au congo qui est désabusé de
la chose politique et n'a plus d'intérêt
l'abstention est probablement très fort
parce que la plupart des gens estiment
que en donnant ses voix ou pas on ne
change pas radicalement le seul issu de
l'élection et dans certaines personnes
ce défaitisme et ce fatalisme qui fait
qu'ils ne vont plus aux urnes
en revanche du côté de l'armée du côté
des ddd forces de sécurité et de défense
beaucoup continuent de voter et soussan
c'est souvent dans ses réservoirs la
queue leu leu que l'attention qu'on a vu
dans la population est comblée et que on
peut atteindre des scores du
participation des taux de participation
aussi élevé que ce que nous avons relevé
donc c'est vrai que il répète dans ce
fétichisme lui dire que on à votre
participation très élevé ou pas très
élevé le vrai problème ici c'est
l'intérêt que les congolais peuvent
encore avoir ou pas pour la chose
politique et malheureusement j'ai
l'impression que les congolais sont de
plus en plus dégoûtés
comme la plupart des habitants de glee
d'afrique centrale du fait que les
leaders à la tête de leur pays ne sont
pas forcément issus des urnes et ne sont
pas prêts à se soumettre au verdict des
urnes ou permettre à d'autres de tenter
leur chance dans la gestion de la chose
commune de la chose publique
beaucoup lui que my on surveillera la
situation dans le pool comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure merci à vous je
rappelle que vous êtes président du club
de l'information africaine